well it's a very special day because we
have today returning to the program Mike
Lindell the CEO and inventor of my
pillow known affectionately to many in
our audience as Mike pillow or even just
pillow the word pillow it's like Madonna
at this point Mike it's really
incredible The Branding around that did
you think that this you would be so
ubiquitous in the United States sort of
cultural milieu at this point
no you know back when I invented my
pillow I worked shows for years just
doing home shows and fairs and and it
was uh it was a hard seven year grind
but then when we did the first
infomercial it kind of went it was
living in my sister's basement and all
of a sudden it you know it just exploded
and uh
um you know it's just uh I guess when we
did that first infomercial going to the
number one infomercial in the world in
30 days right it was uh it was kind of a
you know it was a dream come true the
American dream right so to speak yeah
listen I want to get right into the the
the context and the meat of this because
you and I spoke about a year ago and at
one point it wasn't clear if you
remembered that conversation but I know
you've reviewed it I want to run by you
the following you said over the last
couple years in August that Trump would
be back in office by the end of the
month that was August 2021 you said in
November of 2021 that it would be in the
Supreme Court by Thanksgiving that it
was quote locked in stone you said at
the end of 2021 that it was still
happening by the end of that year you
have made all of these specific time
predictions and as we know none of them
have happened why not
well there's a big reason for that the
evidence I got on January 9th was by a
person which I can come out with his
name now Dennis Montgomery he was a
whistleblower with the CIA he worked
with the CIA and the government for
years developing a thing called Hammer
scorecard okay and this is all the
information he gave me on January 9th
when we were going to release it at the
Cyber Symposium we were told because uh
there's a government gag order on it the
that we cannot release it but Dennis put
in to get it released about the same
time we did our show last year he put
that in and they said they wouldn't
release it we went ahead with the Cyber
Symposium we could show that we had the
data that it was from the 2020 election
but we couldn't show the back end data
there was on the third day they would
not let us show it my lawyer said no
they advised us to you know don't put it
out let's work on this gig or now years
went by and then I had the Moment of
Truth Summit about a month ago on stage
where Dennis has had this to get
released in Nevada I actually put myself
I bought the software now and so I own
it so I have the the X the software the
dentist developed and everything and and
the data from the 2020 election now I
put in Nevada to get it released
um about a month ago just this last
Thursday the government came in and said
you can this is not going to be part of
the gag order so that is big news it's
breaking news I didn't know that when we
were going to get on your show so now we
can release it to the king I can bring
it to my lawsuits in good we're
subpoenaed we subpoenaed on Friday
Brennan Clapper
um Negra Ponte
um Baker We subpoenaed all these guys
you're probably not going to see that in
the news no well I can't imagine that
they'll respond to the subpoenas but
Mike you've mentioned so much let me
just make one comment here Dennis
Montgomery uh a con man I mean just an
out and out con man habitual liar
engaged in five major frauds uh
terrorist software hoax Nevada
gubernatorial bribery Scandal
wiretapping allegations that he has not
been able to prove we're talking about
an out and out con man here
um well you know what you can say that
but you can go to Dennis montgomery.com
now and all that has been completely
fabricated so if you go to Dennis
montgomery.com we put that up just for
comments like yours there because they
have attacked him but hold on a second
Mike I want to make sure I know what
you're saying here you're saying that
the reporting about Dennis Montgomery in
the New York Times uh the register from
the UK Bloomberg the Las Vegas Review
Journal New West Nevada today NPR wired
Courthouse News Service uh a USA Today
Las Vegas I I for it's all fake it's all
a lie yeah you know what David wow and
here's what I'm telling you is I'm
telling you that's why we put up the
David or the I mean the Dennis
montgomery.com page those what they've
done is just the same kind of attacks
I've gotten since I wanted to get rid of
the machines the voting machines in our
country which we'll get I would say I
was the Evangelist getting people I used
to be an addict getting people out of
addiction I have my company and I have
been relentlessly attacked just like
Dennis Montgomery was Dennis was never
arrested Dennis has been a gag order on
his on his data I mean you could say all
you want about Dennis Montgomery but
numbers speak for themselves well but
I'm not saying anything in my defense
Mike I'm just saying what you're alleged
if you got the data which I have and the
government just said now we can show it
to the world you asked me what was
holding this back okay and by the way
the Supreme Court case there is a case
right now in the Supreme Court okay it
is almost 80 percent of what we were
going to have in the original what's the
name of that case I don't have it I mean
you can I can get a Priya David I did
why don't you Caitlyn go go ask her what
the name of that what the name of the
cake so okay I mean there's just so much
here Mike so the 10-year media record
that goes from 2012 to 2022 on Dennis
Montgomery you're saying that was a
decade-long effort to smear him and it's
all fake to to suppress who they didn't
want his data coming out to the world
and if you if you go back there was even
back in 2017 on Fox there was Sean
Hannity Sarah Carter another one they
brought up Dennis Montgomery it all got
pushed out of the table they did not not
just the 2020 election this is the
software is uh it goes very deeper than
that and that's why the government just
said that we can release the 2020
election because that's my evidence
David right I do have lawsuits against
Me by companies uh Dominion which
everybody seems to protect these
companies that nobody knew of before
esns hard diable that you paid for as a
taxpayer and my whole thing is here is
you know what we can't have computers
running our elections you just had it in
Georgia where a Democrat this nice lady
her husband got zero votes in her own
Precinct and she they looked into it she
three Democrats she went from third to
four okay but Mike where I want to try
because you have so many different areas
in which you you claim expertise and
involvement I wanted we're jumping
around a lot let's kind of go
sequentially a little bit if we can so
you're going to get us the name of the
Supreme Court case you say that Dennis
Montgomery has been smeared over a
10-year period by 30 different media
Outlets okay the FBI we now know they
took the pillow phone at the Hardys
drive through
um just to set the context do you
frequently go to Hardee's is that a
common place you go okay that's pretty
funny David no it's not a joke but you
know I was coming back from a hunting
trip and I was late to get back I was
filming commercials with my
entrepreneurs for mystore.com they were
all waiting here and I said we've got to
go through a drive through
and by the way when they surrounded me
they weren't dressed like FBI they were
no I know I know that's what happened at
night I would have bashed through them
and went to find a law enforcement
office you would have you would have
fled you're saying I would have
absolutely because they would they
didn't identify themselves I would have
thought they were bad guys I would if it
had been a night I I stepped out of my
car and said um who are you and what do
you want very loud so other people could
hear yeah and one guy says FBI and I
said show me your badge I don't believe
you another one to my right he says show
me yours I figure if they each had
badges I'll give them that okay and we
pulled and started talking fair so I I'm
again I'm curious because you there's a
question of how they knew you would be
there do you often go to Hardee's it's
just a it's not a joke no and I'm never
I'm never in that town I never eat in
that town it was an hour and a half from
where I live okay and I was like I say I
was down in another state hunting they
obviously tracked me which was illegal
to track me they didn't have a warrant
and so that we did sue the government
and the FBI we've sued him I know I know
you have and we first fifth and sixth
amendment rights I'm
shocked you didn't add in and more
amendments to the lawsuit but we'll get
to that Mike I'm not I'm not a lawyer
the lawyers are lawyers I I my whole
thing was when they said we want your
phone yeah I said no you're not getting
my phone I said I want you know arrest
me I've done nothing Well he said no
we're not going to arrest you I said
well I want to call my lawyer they said
no you don't get to call your lawyer and
I said well let me get this straight if
you arrest me I can call a lawyer but if
I if you don't arrest me I can't call a
lawyer but you can take my personal
property and this day everything's on a
person's phone and uh so they did let me
call the lawyer eventually here's what I
want to ask you about all of this Mike
I've previously interviewed two
individuals one named Carter page one
named Roger Stone
during the interviews they said they did
not believe they were going to be
charged ever and of course they
ultimately were is your expectation at
this point in time that you are going to
be criminally charged no that's not what
they're looking into they're looking
into someone else somebody else I even
asked him about January 6. I said it's a
symbolving January 6 and they said no
and I said well why don't you bring me
there because I've offered to go there
even though I wasn't there on January
6th to show them all this evidence that
I can now show okay and um no absolutely
not that's not what this is about they
want stuff in there about a about a case
in Colorado Okay this County Clerk came
Tina Peters yes and did her job I didn't
know her back then so this is nothing to
do this is like the Cyber Symposium
going forward and uh they're just
looking into the phone records by the
way which uh they could have got I said
here you go I have nothing to hide I'm
as transparent as they come David on the
issue of Tina Peters there have been
allegations I've read that at one point
you were essentially helping her hide
out to evade Justice is that true
the uh the in in after the Cyber
Symposium she I didn't I didn't fly
either but she made it to her lawyers
took her to Texas
um and when you say I'm hiding her out
no I didn't I didn't hide her out you
weren't involved in getting her to Texas
she wasn't at a property you own you
weren't paying for a hotel room or
anything communication there whatsoever
I've got the name of that lawsuit if you
want please
um um no that's not that's not the
Nevada One the Nevada lawsuit is
Montgomery versus e-trepid and case
number
306. we're looking for the Supreme Court
case you mentioned I want the Supreme
Court
okay
that that is like the Supreme Court for
the for the um election laws okay we'll
get that Supreme Court case I want to go
back to just one more detail of the FBI
thing then we'll move on to the machines
and everything else yeah you just
mentioned a few minutes ago you said to
the FBI agents I'd rather go to jail
than give up my phone
because I knew I hadn't I've never done
I haven't done anything wrong no I get
that money but David here's my whole
reason okay the way we're at in our
country right now ever to get rid of
these machines I don't care if you're a
Democrat or Republican yeah the biggest
problem we have is law fair where Fox
News Newsmax Salem media none of these
guys talk the only one that ever talks
about it is people like you or Jimmy
Kimmel and I'm gladly come on your show
where I can actually say speak out these
guys they and you and they've never said
one thing even 2 000 meals Newsmax and
fox will not let them on because of law
fair okay I thought gee maybe this would
be big enough news well they would put
it on Fox and they did okay the way they
did my question though was just going to
be you know that when you get arrested
they take all your stuff so like you
would have had to give up the phone
anyway right you know that but but I
would but Fox and Newsmax would have
Maybe started reporting about the
biggest gorilla that we have to get rid
of these Electronics I see if you had
gotten us arrested it would have gotten
publicity it's not overturning elections
it's getting rid of these machines and
having paper ballots hand counted like
so many other countries do the
Netherlands France Germany instead these
other countries that are gone forever
like Venezuela Australia they don't get
to ever have elections again their
selections and this has been proven out
there it's been proven over and over
again with these machine companies but
nobody will talk about it because of
what smartmatic did February 4th of 2021
when they sued Fox News okay on the
topic of the election I just want
straight from the horse's mouth Europe
2020 election or you want all these
other elections I've been investigating
2020 connected to 24. here's the
question
will Donald Trump be reinstated before
January 2025 which is when the next
winner is scheduled to be inaugurated
what would you like me to say David
whatever you believe I will tell you
whatever you believe I will here's my
answer yeah if we if we don't fix 2020
means getting rid of the electronic
voting machines melt them down and turn
them into prison bars we're not going to
have a country look what the damage has
been done in our country in two years by
what's been going on it's disgusting I
was just in Northern California all
these people there coming up to me
wanting pictures wanting to know him you
know do we have a chance to get ready we
don't like 7.80 gas is there a chance I
said you know what it all started with a
stolen election here's the Supreme Court
case it's called Moore versus Harper
it's case number
21-1271 and that is really critical to
our country because these are all the
things that the Secretary of States did
changed our laws when the legislatures
make the laws okay but to be clear Mike
that's a case I'm familiar with you said
you had a case at the the court this
case has nothing to do with you
no this case is is almost identical to
what we were going to bring to the
Supreme Court okay but this case has
nothing to do with this actually got to
the Supreme Court okay right now we
don't have to put a new one in we are
going to put one down with this evidence
and stuff to get rid of the machines but
what we want here is done in Arizona and
we've done in Alabama two preliminary
Junctions to get rid of these electronic
voting machines what we want on the
program what we want on the program is
just Clarity because I don't want
anybody to misunderstand when you said
you have that case that this case you
just cited has nothing to do with you
this case here is everything I would
have wanted to do but they they got they
we're in two tracks coming to the
Supreme Court okay they got there first
got it understood right to close one
other loop and we are making progress
here even if it doesn't realize that
just I'm going to tell you something
just when you say you or whatever this
is all me that everything every Focus
out there all across our country
um is to get rid of these electronic
voting machines which we will get to
momentarily so that I can move on to
that I didn't get an answer from you
about Will trump be reinstated before
January 25 what's your belief
my belief is I would hope that but but
you know I I can't say there's no with
the evidence now yeah that would come
out that I can release with Dennis
Montgomery I don't know you know I don't
know in the way the way we're in now
nothing it's it's like um we've never
been in an anomaly like this in history
where where there's it's a lawless
Society you have you know you have
things going on where you're going how
does Pennsylvania turn in their electors
which is illegal with more votes than
voters that doesn't happen of course
yeah but that's that did happen it did
not happen it happened David no you're
then you're misconstrued or lying they
they turned in their electors with more
votes than voters in Pennsylvania and
every and it went through and everyone's
called him out on it but they've it's
still sitting there it hasn't been
pulled down and looked at to say how did
this happen okay you know and and that's
a fact you can sit here you can have
Alan Duke fact check you if you'd like
there is no state that has more yeah
anything like this uh you know in like
in in Georgia when that Democrat got
zero votes they had to look at it
because they didn't they could have gave
her two or her and her husband at least
got a vote another Democrat in Georgia
this is this summer another Democrat
this other lady she got 3 700 votes and
she wasn't on the ballot Mike my head is
spit let's I want to try to do the the
we will all benefit the most and you
will come through the most credibly if
we can kind of go item by item so let's
let's walk through these things one at a
time we're now kind of getting close to
the machine conversation earlier this
month or late September I don't have the
date in front of me the Supreme Court
declined to take up the case to dismiss
the defamation suit against you by
Dominion voting systems for over a
billion dollars why do you believe one
of the most conservative Supreme Courts
in the last hundred years did not step
in on your behalf they they did not
allow the appeal they were waiting for
the appeal they wanted to the the Kate
that we are cured the way you're saying
you're misconstrued the case we asked to
appeal it to appeal the case and they
said no you're going to have to wait
till it runs its course that's all they
said yes we were trying something
there's so many things out of the box
here that haven't that uh this these
this law fair has now been done in our
country since 1798. remember these guys
sued over 200 people in platforms it's
never been done before where where it
shut up all the media around the country
instantly okay so what we're trying
everything uh and uh you know if they
want us to run which would be normal you
run your case then you do your appeal we
wanted to appeal right now we're doing
everything our lawyers are doing to get
this love Fair behind us so then we can
go hey you guys look at it we have to
get rid of these machines and save our
country on the machines some of the
comments of the electronic 40 machine
including the polling books the
computers do you know that Wisconsin has
two million more people on their on
their pole on their uh their their
polling books their electronic um uh
database where they pull more two
million more people that live in
Wisconsin are actually on their voter
rolls and you say how do I know this I
have every State's voter rolls before
during who voted and then afterwards I
spent a lot of money over 35 million
dollars trying to get rid of these I
hate to interrupt you but that claim
about Wisconsin is completely untrue the
number hold on Mike let me just oh yeah
hold on hold on I got it from the
Wisconsin Secretary of State you're
wrong who are you going to get it from
two million you can get them I did I got
requests out to every single these are
right off the voter rolls these are
their voter roles David who's sending me
the voter rolls what who's sending you
the voter roll to get them from the
Secretary of States I got them from
every secretary you just said you don't
trust the Secretary of State I don't but
they have to give you it's called a foia
request you can anybody I have to pay
for a lot of them Alabama I had to pay
thirty thousand dollars to get hold on a
second Mike the number of registered
voters on November 1 2020 in Wisconsin
was 3.6 million no you need to David
you're not listening okay the red there
was two million more people on these
things there's a thing called Eric too
okay those are the red or the voters
that are eligible and they're they
haven't been cleaned there was two
million more in Wisconsin just Wisconsin
alone two million more than than actual
can register to vote so to me they can
pull these names it's just like every
state every state has uh at least five
thousand some up to 50 000 people that
voted that don't live in the states
never happened before in history but
hold on a second Mike I we got to be
able to talk sensibly about this and I
think you and I can make some progress
well I'm just telling you I've got all
the numbers you're jumping around from
one thing to another and citing the very
sources that you tell me aren't
trustworthy when I cite them so let's
bring down the temperature just a little
bit Mike hold on hold on Mike hold on
here's the information I have okay the
population of Wisconsin is 5.8 million
and there in 2020 were 3.6 million
registered voters that's the information
I have which piece of data is wrong
okay my data came from the state I don't
know
Secretary of State well okay when that
when you're using numbers that live in
Wisconsin I'm telling you eligible
voters do you understand there's two
million more on the voter rolls more
than the eligible voters in Wisconsin
let me make an argument hold it David
you're doing the population of Wisconsin
obviously anybody under age can't vote
everybody that's not eligible they can't
vote right you got to take that off your
5 million total absolutely and you take
the voter rolls and they haven't been
clean I'll give an example in Alabama
they have over 5 000 people on their
voter rolls that are over 110 years old
Mike hold on a second I haven't been
cleaned let me add another piece of
information let me add another piece of
information
5.8 million people live in Wisconsin
4.5 million are of voting age
3.6 million are registered you get me
the numbers for Wisconsin
oh boy you're gonna get him the vote at
the rotor roll numbers you know David
you should have told me I could give you
the exact numbers because I got them
from the states that's where I'm getting
them that's where I'm getting
I'm getting them from the state that's
right to the secretary of state of
Wisconsin yeah are the wec the web huh
yeah just tell just you can yeah get the
get the Wisconsin I want to know the
numbers that was over the registered
voters over it was two million some give
them the numbers okay
um while we search for that
in all seriousness okay just I
completely seriously
is it possible that maybe Trump's just
not quite as popular as you think he is
and he just lost David here's your
problem here's your problem tell me the
problem and all of you out there I went
on Jimmy Kimmel and Jimmy Kimmel asked
me Mike if this was reversed would you
still be selling in the alarm if your
friend Donald Trump did not win yeah and
if you remember I said absolutely I
would but I don't believe Martian and
post and political came to Minnesota and
questioned everyone in my town it seemed
like would Mike really do that and they
said absolutely he would I have a moral
compass it doesn't matter who won or
lost all these people down in Georgia
and Colorado in this primary this summer
all these elections that we questioned
they were found out in like those and
they were Democrats okay that they got
put in they found out the problem with
the machines and they put them in she
went from third to First another guy
went from second to First this stuff
just happened it doesn't matter if
you're a Democrat a republican quit
talking about overturning an election
I'm talking about getting rid of the
machines okay okay
my evidence was suppressed by the
government the gag order so everything
yes we should have Donald Trump and put
in right away absolutely but I'm glad he
did because we've learned so much from
there we've learned so much that these
machines we've never we haven't machines
growing back David I had Clint Curtis on
my cyber or My Moment of Truth Summit he
made the first algorithms to steal in
the machine he's good friends with
Kamala Harris he voted and now Kim and I
are going around the country talking to
Democrats or Republicans saying hey
let's get rid of these electronic
machines so everybody can we can have a
fair election with paper under camera
and those are our audits okay what's so
hard to understand you keep trying we're
not getting to the bottom of the machine
we're not focusing on Donald Trump let
me ask because we're getting to the end
of our time and we have a lot of other
things to talk about a couple just quick
things that came from the odd audience
when you talk about the machines I just
want to clarify you mean electronic
voting machines and those because people
write to me and they say I'm worried
Mike pillow is gonna come after my
espresso machine my lathe my all these
other type I'm sure I'm sure they do
David now you're just being sarcastic
and the little left-wing humor I'm not
I'm not that could be your headline Mike
Lindell wants to get rid of the machine
I will tell you this yeah we're in an
apex in history okay where the
technology we have out there like in in
um
Australia where they use drones to come
down and tell you to go back in your
house the stuff is going on there well
we have been robots and everything and
everything run by computers if you look
at the everything that can be hacked you
got you know credit cards companies get
hacked businesses get hacked yes
um uh Gaslight or gas we get gas
companies get hacked all these things
that hacked when they get hacked you
have it all involves money or insurance
so you have you know the good Geeks and
they patch it up who did this attack who
did this Cyber attack who broke into my
computer and they fix it and they put up
better protection virus protection but
when it happens in an election you can
lose your country that's all I'm about I
don't know I just wanted to clarify that
that's all that if you if you're gonna
take an election which China was
involved in this I'll say it straight
out you just seen where the guy the code
check or whatever it was a call check I
believe in Michigan just got indicted
arrested and uh for China to be involved
in the 2020 election that went out that
actually went out in the news just a
week ago okay I'm telling you that with
with computers we just did the
preliminary injunction down in Arizona
that judge said why why um their hand
county is vulnerable too and here's what
my attorney said he said you know what
when you have a computer you can you can
change one number you can do anything
you hack in and you can do it can affect
Millions where if you had to do the same
thing with paper you'd have to have a
whole cabal of people you would have to
have thousands and thousands of people
okay instead of having you know to be
protected our elections need to be
protected they do all of our elections
right down to the school boards you
can't have people breaking in and
hacking into computers that's not such a
thing and David doesn't it doesn't it
bother you that these guys have never
said hey we have nothing to hide show us
what's inside these computers instead
they attacked Tina Peters who that image
is up on my platform Frank speech the
image is there it shows 100 percent the
Dominion and the Secretary of State
Jenna Griswold committed felonies and
deleted the 2020 election Mike it's
really hard to do these interviews
because we have so many different things
that you kind of Jump Around
the dumb question about getting rid of
machines if you want to be a humorous
interview
um you know get rid of my espresso
machine give me a break espresso please
okay for a coffee guy you're doing
coffee I'm sure you have all kinds of
people that's a headline Mike wants to
get rid of the machine I guarantee you
that's not gonna that's not gonna be the
heading machines computers used in our
voter rolls they're falsely inflated I
appreciate you clarifying electronic
polling books anything with our
elections let's narrow just a few
questions and these should be really
short answers and these are genuine
questions from the audience how much do
you believe you spent on legal fees
since this all started
um I don't know but I've got over 35
million in County uh developing a
platform but for myfrankspeach.com
lawyers cyber experts um
um you know so put it on it's a lot of
money Fair are you so many people wanted
to know you know Trump is known for like
not getting a lot of sleep he's just
work you know supposedly working at all
hours of the day and stuff how much
sleep do you get are you one of these
very little sleep like super high
performance guys no but I do when I do
sleep it's quality David you should have
one of my pillows too
send you some pillows and sheets it will
actually help you sleep I will test that
there's a reason we've sold 76 million
of them and you know what Mike if it if
it's good I will tell the audience that
it's the best way absolutely everyone
it'll change your life okay there's a
difference between time of spending and
better quality sleep but so how much
sleep do you get would you say
I probably sleep six to eight hours yeah
that's good uh on the coffee the my
coffee that is taking the World by storm
I was surprised as a there it is I was
surprised that you get the beans from
another country when they could be grown
in Hawaii and keep it all made in the
USA why this is uh this is a my store
platform this isn't me these are all U.S
entrepreneurs and USA products so I met
this family down in Florida and they go
from their field is in Honduras they
bring it here and they do everything
here they've been a family-owned
business for about 15 years but the
coffee was so good they said can we call
my copy I said yeah you guys I'll put my
stamp of approval on it that's their
business not my business this is a
driver that brings people to this
platform my pill mystore.com is for
entrepreneurs and USA made products
these guys there's thousands of they
don't have a platform like Amazon where
they get copied by China products and
they get lost here we bring people to
them we just launched the my store
shopping channel two days ago all these
entrepreneurs their stories are out
there these out they have families and
stuff and they've they've started out
small now we're giving them a platform
so everyone's got a story behind it
David these are and it doesn't matter
what political politics are in not
people it might I have Democrats
liberals conservative Republicans
everybody we're like a big family here
at um my pill in my store the day the
FBI truck you know it was sad when the
FBI took my phone four of these
entrepreneurs one of them got debanked
just because oh they were they were they
have a platform they're going to be up
on my store they got debate three of
them were afraid oh Michael don't know
the FBI they're trying to silence my
voice because they want to keep the
machines and they want to destroy your
country with these take over these
machines or take over your country with
the voting machines David the voting
machines quick hitting I'm putting
Donald Trump in tomorrow out of your
head my whole focus is I will not let up
when I know what these machines keep
doing what people keep using when those
Democrats got attacked in Georgia I've
talked to them it doesn't matter if
you're a Democrat or Republican look at
Brad ransomer if you watch my show David
I say more bad things about Brad
rasenberger Chris Carr and and Brian
Camp the triple counter crime down in
Georgia Rapids okay they're all
Republicans
election in Georgia good luck if you're
a democrat in Georgia
all right Mike I'm sweating from so much
that we covered I don't know how you do
this
16 18 hours a day it's I'm going to need
a few days to recover from this but you
have truly said it I do it from morning
till night because I want to save our
country right I want to have election s
are for my children your children your
grandchildren our friends our neighbors
everybody all right and I do have that
right now
so
um in Wisconsin the Secretary of State
declared that the use of an unmanned
Dropbox is was illegal as was the
guidance that anyone who could declare
themselves and definitely confined to
avoid signature verification and voter
ID requirements maker hundreds of
thousands if not millions of ballots
illegal under Wisconsin law that's not
what I wanted from but that's okay
that's fair and that's I believe that
was an ADA issue some of the boxes were
not uh they did a full investigation
Wisconsin Yeah by Michael game and ex
Supreme Court uh judge in Wisconsin and
they said that the Wisconsin that he
said to decertify because it was all the
fraud that they found Robin Voss head of
the house there said it's the
certifications there were felony charges
pressed against the wec in Wisconsin
those got suspiciously dropped because
of standing by the way David do you know
that no judge in the United States has
looked at the evidence from the 2020
election that is not my understanding no
it's a hundred percent they've kicked
them all out for understanding everyone
if you find one that has looked at the
evidence David you call me I'll give you
as many pillars as you want for your
whole audience don't judge has looked at
the evidence I will do it kicked it out
for standing every single one I will
find it
none of them kicked it out on marriage
CEO and inventor of my pillow uh we are
gonna take a moment to recover here from
the extremely high level of energy uh
Mike it's always fascinating to talk to
you I really do appreciate your time and
hope to speak to you again and I
appreciate you have me on your show you
guys are you guys I would come on
anytime it's a shame that no one's let
anybody on Fox news or Newsmax I agree
David you know I enjoy your little
machine sarcasm don't give me they
should have you on I believe you should
be on Fox I want you on Fox every day
seriously and I will uh I will send you
some pillows here my assistant I would
like you to try them out and I need you
need to sleep better David I do it's
better than like a goose down pillow no
no Goose that's the worst thing for you
because your cervical nerves in your
neck when you're sleeping on down it
goes down and you're bending your
cervical nerves and your vertebral
arteries so you end up using your arm
folding your pillow you get sleep
interruptions I could talk to you all
day about this I will try the pillow
Mike I will try it and I will review it
genuinely okay all right thanks Mike
thank you bye